hey guys it's evan i wanted to make a
quick video today because I'm little
frustrated with something in my business
and I wanted to share that with you and
vent a little bit a challenge I'm facing
right now is I'm working on a project
and I'm not fully committed to it I've
been working on this book deal and since
i started my website almost in the
beginning i've had people come at me
with offers to make a book deal and I've
always pushed it back I pushed it back
because it seemed like one a lot of work
and I don't really enjoy writing I I
like the end result of my writing you
know when I see somebody read what I've
written and they're inspired and they
take action it makes me feel good I'm
proud of what I wrote but I don't enjoy
the process of writing so they thought
of this huge book was was stressful and
an overwhelming so I thought like what
don't do it I don't have a need for it
and the second reason was a lot of times
that publishers won't do much to promote
your book they'll pick some authors and
I'll do some promotion with them but for
a lot of people they don't do much in
the promotion side and I didn't want to
put all this effort into a book and then
just have it die and sit on the shelves
I guess the final reason was a lot of
authors use a book as a way to have some
credibility to say hey I'm the author of
this book and open doors for me I always
had my website which which is powerful
and I can use that to say hey I'm the
foundry of mechanical calm show them
some stats and that opens doors for me
so I've never had a credibility issue in
having to need a book to say that I'm
somebody so that's the backstory I've
been working with my agent Steve and
he's telling me I need a book deal and I
said Steve okay you know what if if you
can get me a good deal get me a good
deal with a good upfront payment show me
that the publisher is committed to this
and they're gonna help promote it and
and they're willing to pay something up
front a good good amount up front then
then I'm on board I want to do this
because i like the thought of it if
everything works out and so I told them
that and
you ran with it and he helped me create
a book proposal and he gave it to one of
the top book agents in in America and
she looked at it and she liked it and
she wanted more information and she said
okay give me a sample chapter and I
didn't have a sample chapter ready to go
and I put something together quickly
that was okay not my best stuff not
something that I can really be proud of
mostly because I wasn't committed to
this project yeah right i'm waiting for
steve to get me that deal before i go
out and put my all into it and that's
not enough so the feedback came back on
the chapter that it was too boring it
was too vanilla you know wasn't it
wasn't good enough it wasn't a
best-seller kind of material and I kind
of knew that when I created it it wasn't
my best stuff it's not something I'm
really proud of and and that's bad for
business I know we all have these
projects that we are working on that
were not fully committed to and you have
to decide should I keep doing this or
should I drop it and in my case I also
made my agent looked a little back now
he has a reputation with with the book
agent so they know each other and he's
vouching for me and so I want to deliver
for him as well as you know create this
book it's gonna be awesome for for all
you guys and helping entrepreneurs and
so today I made the decision after the
frustration that I have to commit myself
to this project you know it's either I I
do this and I'm focused on it and I put
everything into it and I write an
amazing sample chapter or I just let it
drop and say listen I don't want to do a
book deal and I think I'm far enough
along the road you know Steve's put in a
ton of time and he's put me in touch
with a great book agent who represents
some of the biggest names in the
industry and she likes the idea so I'm
about as close to a book deal as I can
get without getting a book deal and all
that's missing is is a really great
sample chapter and it means me working
to get that sample chapter and so I have
to commit to it
and that's what I'm going to do so as
much as it pains me to start doing the
work without having the deal it's
required to make this project happen
it's either that or I drop it and I
don't want to drop it so a little
frustration but I actually feel better
telling you guys about it making this
video and so the next week or two are
going to invest a lot of time into
making that sample chapter awesome and
if you're interested maybe i'll post a
quick update later on let me know in the
comments below and for any of you who
are facing the same thing you have some
kind of challenge or problem project
you're working on that you know you're
not giving your all at it's frustrating
at least it's frustrating for me it
should be frustrating for you you don't
want to put out stuff that's just okay
it should be your best or shouldn't be
at all and so you have to make a
decision you know either commit to it
make it happen do something every day to
move that project forward or drop it and
move on to something else that you are
more passionate about thank you for
letting me share this with you guys
today I feel better already ready to go
on and it's a wednesday sewing to be
filming all my videos this afternoon I
feel like I've unload a little bit so
thanks for that I'd love to hear what
you have to think let me know in the
comments below if you're going through
something similar or if you want more
more details on what I'm doing please
leave it in the comments below I really
guys you I love seeing that stuff come
in you really make my morning every time
I'm gonna check my comments so thank you
guys and I'll see you soon
you